es war einmal schneewittchen als kind
habe ich das märchen auf dieser
schallplatte einige hundert mal gehört
die geschichte hat sich bei mir
eingebrannt genauso wie diese bilder von
meiner lieblings märchenfigur
lohr am main soll schneewittchens
heimatstadt sein ist überall zu lesen
heimatstadt
ich denke es handelt sich um ein märchen
ich fahre hin und im schloss von lohr
treffe ich karl heinz bartels gelernte
apotheker und hobbyfahrer logo er hat
viele hinweise gefunden die darauf
hindeuten dass die gebrüder grimm beim
schreiben ihrer fabel eine konkrete
familie vor augen hatte eine familie aus
dem schloss der vater war oberamtmann
das war also fast könig gleich es gab
eine stiefmutter die nachweislich ihre
kinder bevorzugt hat das soll der
berühmte spiegel der stiefmutter sein
er kann zwar nicht sprechen trägt aber
diese inschriften ein kunstwerk aus der
spiegel und glasmanufaktur von lohr
wir sagen immer wenn schneewittchen
gelebt hat dann in diesem jahr geboren
und so kam es dass die stadt sich zur
heimat einer märchenfigur erklärte eine
neue skulptur soll diesen anspruch
unterstreichen
auch deshalb bin ich hergekommen das
neue schneewittchen ansehen wie später
auch hunderte touristen
der künstler peter witt stadt hat es
entworfen ich bin gespannt er zeigt mir
die gipsfigur in seinem garten
was soll ich sagen ich bin überrascht
schlagartig fällt mir medusa ein jenes
wesen aus der griechischen mythologie
deren kopf mit schlangen überdeckt war
kein vergleich mit meinem zarten
schneewittchen
es ist nicht meine art gegen den strich
zu arbeiten oder auch zu provozieren wie
mir das oft nahe gelegt wird ich denke
ich habe meinen stil entwickelt und über
diesen möchte ich mich natürlich war der
behaupten und das ist der grund für
diese so entstand eine figur mit
schneewittchen sorgt für streit in der
stadt
einer umfrage zufolge lehnen 90 prozent
der bürger die skulptur ab sie passe
einfach nicht zu lohr sagen sie und sie
verstehen nicht dass die stadt dafür
mehr als 100.000 euro auf den tisch
gelegt hat die empörung der bürger hat
sogar einen gesprächskreis ins leben
gerufen
man könnte sagen eine task force die in
zukunft verhindern will dass an den
ohren vorbei entschieden wird wenn es um
kunst geht die die stadt repräsentiert
ich verstehe auf alle fälle dass man als
künstler nicht dem schönheitsideal
unbedingt entsprechen will aber dem
ganzen dann so krass zu widersprechen
halte ich für eine provokation die
deutlich über das nötige über den
nötigen denkanstoß den kunst vielleicht
geben sollte hinausgeht
er muss die wogen wieder glätten
sozusagen den vergifteten apfel dem sein
vorgänger hinterlassen hat wieder aus
der welt schaffen
bürgermeister mario paul aber die teure
statue muss er aufstellen lassen da
führt kein weg mehr daran vorbei vertrag
ist vertrag
ich höre heraus er findet die statue
wohl gar nicht schlecht schneewittchen
ist fluch und segen zugleich einerseits
wirklich sympathieträger weltweit
bekannt auf der anderen seite ist der
umgang damit nicht gerade einfach und es
war immer wieder auch der vorwurf sonst
zu hören also wir wollen hier keine
disney stadt ja wir wollen hier kein
schneewittchen kitsch haben
doch ist es nicht gerade der kitsch der
beim märchen die sehnsüchte erfüllt ich
bin verwirrt und frage mich ob meine
vorstellung von schneewittchen noch
zeitgemäß ist
was würden die gebrüder grimm wohl zu
kitsch staatskultur sagen
bei den gesprächsrunden im alten
weinhaus stößt sie jedenfalls nicht nur
auf ablehnung
eine gewisse ästhetik gewöhnt man sich
um geschmack ist trainierbar
und je öfter ich das ding sehe desto
besser gefällt werden wenn es dann eines
tages in bronze dasteht ist die wirkung
noch mal eine andere als nur das bild
aus der zeitung wer sich kennen mit
meinem schneewittchen hat die lora
statue so gar nichts am hut muss sich
nun radikal umdenken
ich warte noch ein wenig muss noch mal
näher hinschauen ob das echte
schneewittchen damals auch so
verschmitzt gelächelt hat